[Music]
I need some coffee when you come John
can you make this up damn it
it's like deja vu watching the new
Roseanne man not just the guys all the
cast members are back the original
series turned Sara Gilbert into a star
and now watching the same thing happened
to the young actress who plays Sarah's
daughter and McKenney even looking at
you and kind of even your mannerisms I
get a bit of a Sara Gilbert throwback
bye it's so versatile I love it and it's
like it's insane how uncanny our
resemblance true it is 18 year old Emma
wasn't even born yet when a rose and
went off the air she prepared for her
role as Darlene's daughter Harris by
watching reruns you know what I don't
need to get yelled at by some stupid old
hillbilly ours is a mix of Darlene with
her little sassy one-liner than her dry
humor and Roseanne's obviously a little
bit more straight forward a little bit
more savage Paris is like the perfect
mix of the two I want you to rinse off
this plate in the sink whatever
[Music]
what is that like when you are filming
the fight scene with one of television
comedies icon it's insane like Roseanne
is the coolest thought and she gives you
the best notes on set she gives you like
it's just a very collaborative saying
you're smart for a kid but you're still
dumb for a person it speaking of like
comedy gold you've got Sara Gilbert and
Johnny Galecki as your mom and dad which
is pretty pretty damn cool
but no Johnny comes back in an episode
to your birthday yes after being gone
for years yeah what's that like Oh
amazing Johnny Galecki is a class out on
the first day of Sat he brought records
like vinyl records of Wonder Woman for
me and Jaden and Ames the three
newcomers just like sweet it's like a
nice gesture and it was really rad to
work with him what are some of the
lessons that you've learned from Sarah
she is a baller she's got the best work
ethic honestly that I've ever seen she
would be doing the talk in the morning
and then come to Roseanne you know the
stages were right next to each other but
she would be going back and forth I love
Sarah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]